- Colombia!
- Colombia, food!
(upbeat music)
- There is no mistaking
that this is from Colombia.
- Are these the colors
of the Colombian flag?
- Look.
- Oh it is.
- There it is.
- Woah, didn't see that one coming.
- Oh, dude, this smells like
Guarana, the Brazilian drink.
- No, it does not!
- [Man] Yeah it does.
- [Woman] No, it doesn't.
- It kinda tastes like
a melted shaved ice.
- I love it, it's really good.
- Just pull, oh, yeah.
- Ow, ow.
- Like a plantain pancake, almost.
- It's like, they were like,
let's take all the best parts
of a plantain and just like...
- Let's take the sweet
part and get rid of it.
- This is substantial.
If you go to a club and you're drinking,
you have a couple of
these, you'll be fine.
- Love plantains when they're fried once,
I love 'em even more
if they're fried twice.
- I kinda think it looks
like a Pokeball that was
discovered by Indiana Jones.
- (laughs loudly) It's an
ancient stone Pokeball.
- It looks like the thing from Splice.
- Also no one's seen Splice--
- I've never seen--
- Have you seen Splice?
Have you seen Splice?
- Mmm, mmm.
- On the spectrum between,
like, sweet, and cheese,
it's like, smack-dab in the middle.
- God damn it, Colombia,
you're just so good.
- This is good 'cause it's food
and also doubles as a frisbee.
- This chorizo smells incredible.
- Wow.
- Yup, wow.
- There's so much density
of spice in that chorizo.
- We don't need this bread
it's just extra carbs.
- Get rid of it, we
don't need those carbs.
- Is it cow tongue?
- This is what they use to say, "moo."
- This isn't just strips of tongue.
This is an entire tongue.
- No, this is an entire tongue.
(squeals)
- All right.
- This is really good.
- It's super soft.
- That is some buttery-ass tongue.
- This is a giant Nutter Butter.
- Is this a Colombian Oreo?
- I know how it's going to
break, so I want to punch it.
- Ooh, nice clean break.
- Hahhh!
- Mmmm, I really like it.
- Yeah, it's really good.
- Fun to eat, hard to punch.
(upbeat music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah, mhm.
(whooshing)
- You don't know the half of it.